.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Schwungvolle Panflötenmusik *
Ich finde es extrem spannend, etwas
zu entwickeln, und zwar von A bis Z.
Nicht einfach irgendwo ...
... für eine Grossfirma zu sitzen
und einfach ein Rädchen zu sein.
Sondern von A bis Z
etwas gestalten zu können.
Und das nach meinen Vorstellungen.
Möglichst gerecht, möglichst fair -
und den Leuten
etwas vermitteln zu können.
Thomas Schwegler
baut in Peru Kaffee an.
Mit Erfolg - seine Kaffeebohnen
werden weltweit
mit Bestnoten ausgezeichnet.
Finanziell trägt sein Unternehmen
noch keine grossen Früchte.
Trotzdem teilt er seinen
Erfolg mit den Einheimischen.
Was treibt ihn an?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Ich passiere endlose Schotterwege,
um zu Thomas Schwegler zu gelangen.
Von Lima rauf auf 5'000 m,
über die Anden,
runter Richtung Amazonasbecken.
15 Std. dauert es,
bis ich in Chanchamayo,
einem der entlegensten Flecken Perus
ankomme.
Auf Schweglers Farm.
* Zarte Panflötenmusik *
Der 44-Jährige
kam zufällig zum Kaffee.
2005 reiste er
für eine Non-Profit-Organisation
nach Südamerika.
Er unterstützte eine Kaffee-
kooperative, wurde Kaffeehändler.
Vor sieben Jahren entschied er sich,
selber Kaffee anzupflanzen.
Meine Frau fragte mich irgendwann:
"Warum produzierst du nicht selbst?"
"Dann kannst du
die Qualität steuern."
Aber so eine Farm aufzubauen,
das klingt so schön.
Die Leute denken an
ein grosses Farmhaus, eine Hazienda.
Und ...
Die Realität ist nicht so.
Wir mussten viel investieren
und sind immer noch am Anfang.
* Leichte Panflötenmusik *
Er produziert Fair-Trade-Kaffee,
beliefert u.a. ein Schweizer
Luxuskaufhaus und eine Hotelkette.
* Leichte Panflötenmusik *
Das Sagen hier
hat allerdings nicht Schwegler,
sondern seine peruanische Frau
Gisella.
Der Kaffee ist sehr trocken.
Er müsste zwischen
elf und 13 sein.
Er hat 9,3.
Er ist sehr trocken.
Wir lagern ihn,
dass er Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen kann,
bis er auf elf ist.
Die Farm von
Gisella und Thomas Schwegler
ist gleichzeitig auch ihr Zuhause.
Hier leben sie zusammen
mit einem Teil der Angestellten
sowie zehn Hunden.
* Sanfte Panflötenmusik,
Kinderstimmen *
Schwegler
ist für den Handel zuständig.
Die Internetverbindung
ist miserabel,
das Abwickeln der Geschäfte
deshalb mühsam.
Irgendwann habe ich herausgefunden,
dass unser Container
genau auf dem Schiff war,
auf dem 2 t Kokain gefunden wurden.
Also einer der grösseren Funde.
Und ...
Ich habe
mit einem Röster gesprochen,
der auch schon
einen ähnlichen Fall hatte.
Er sagte,
sein Kaffee sei nie mehr angekommen.
Wir haben Glück.
Ich habe eine E-Mail erhalten,
dass der Kaffee
morgen in Bremerhaven ist.
Dann kann ich endlich
die Kunden beliefern.
Die Hälfte des Jahres
verbringt er in der Schweiz.
Seine Frau ist immer hier.
Deshalb besitzen sie so viele Hunde.
Die geben ihr
ein Gefühl von Sicherheit.
* Dynamische Panflötenmusik *
Im Dorf höre ich
nur Positives über Schwegler,
er setze sich
immer wieder für die Region ein.
Ist Chanchamayo
seine neue Heimat geworden?
Wir haben hier 2012 angefangen
und Pionierarbeit geleistet.
Es gab z.T. noch keine Wege.
Nachbarn und Bauern bauten schon an,
wussten aber nicht,
wie den Kaffee runterbringen.
Wenn man etwas erarbeitet
und in einer Gemeinschaft lebt,
dann wird das schon ...
Ich finde Heimat einen etwas ...
... einen etwas zu grosser Begriff.
Aber ich komme immer gerne hierher.
Ihm ist wichtig, dass die Einheimi-
schen von seinem Erfolg profitieren.
Als Nächstes will Schwegler
eine neue Schule bauen.
Dafür macht er Werbung.
Keine Schule?
- Wir haben Ferien.
Kommt auch zum Treffen heute!
Um 17 Uhr in der Schule, ja?
Nos vemos!
Ein halbes Poulet.
Es ist schon zugeschnitten.
Perfekt.
Muy bien.
Hermila Pajares
ist die Besitzerin des Dorfladens,
der zugleich auch ihre Wohnung ist.
Ich mache gerne Brot, aber es ist
viel Arbeit mit Holz zu feuern.
Ich träume
von einem Gas- oder Elektroofen.
Für meine Kinder wünsche ich mir,
dass sie einmal studieren,
dass sie vorwärts kommen und
etwas aus ihrem Leben machen können.
* Piepen *
Nicht alle denken wie die fünffache
Mutter, erzählt mir Schwegler.
Viele haben
vor dem Thema Bildung auch Angst.
Die Kinder sind nicht mehr hier,
sie studieren unten in der Stadt.
Das weckt auch Ängste.
Angst vor dem Alleinsein?
- Es ist auch eine Altersvorsorge.
Die Kinder sorgen hier
für die Eltern.
Die Eltern habe nichts, keine AHV.
Er sei nicht primär
Entwicklungshelfer,
betont er immer wieder,
sondern Geschäftsmann.
Sein Fokus
liege beim Aufbau seiner Kaffeemarke.
* Schwungvolle Panflötenmusik *
Gerade wird die Süsse
der Kaffeebeeren geprüft.
Den Lead hat auch hier seine Frau.
Der Wert ist sehr hoch, 23 Brix.
Sie hat das Chef-Gen,
sagen wir es mal so.
Sie ist in dem Sinn
vielleicht auch etwas thougher.
Sie kann gut mit den Leuten umgehen
und sie hat ihre Linie.
Ich bin eher der Teamplayer.
Auch in Peru ist es vielleicht
für eine Peruanerin einfacher,
die Leute zu führen,
als für einen Schweizer.
Kennen gelernt haben sie sich 2008
in einem Klub in Lima.
Gar nicht schlecht.
Sehr reif.
Er war ein bisschen anstrengend.
Anfangs hat er mir
nicht besonders gefallen.
Er war ein Freund eines Freundes.
Wir haben ein bisschen geredet,
aber verstanden
haben wir uns nicht sonderlich.
Nach ein paarmal treffen
haben wir uns verliebt -
ich und mein Thomas
mit den blauen Augen.
Kinder, ein Thema?
Zwei.
Willst du nicht drei?
- Zwei oder drei.
Die Frage ist, wann.
Kinder müssen warten. Der Aufbau
der Firma hält sie zu sehr auf Trab.
* Abenteuerliche Musik *
Die Strassen
erschweren die Arbeit immens.
Er zeigt mir eine, die während der
Regenzeit glitschig sei wie Seife.
Das Problem sind primär die Kurven.
Wenn man nämlich
die nicht kriegt ...
Wenn man 1'000 kg geladen hat,
kann man in der Kurve nicht
rückwärts fahren und korrigieren.
Bergauf geht es vielleicht,
abwärts nicht.
Der Druck von hinten ist zu gross.
Man sieht es nicht,
aber da geht es sehr steil bergab.
Sollten die Bremsen nicht mehr
funktionieren, stürzt man ab.
Er will den Verantwortlichen
für Strassenbau der Region
von einer Sanierung überzeugen.
Der Region fehle es nicht an Geld.
Aber Korruption
sei in Peru ein grosses Thema.
Wir fahren
zum Strassenbauverantwortlichen.
Wo dieser wohnt,
weiss Schwegler nicht genau.
Buenas tardes.
Ich suche
Herrn Edgar Montes.
Senor Edgar Montes.
Er wohnt da weiter oben.
- Weiter oben?
Ja, fahren Sie da hoch.
Dort ist sein Haus.
Danke, sehr nett.
Haben Sie keinen Termin
mit ihm abgemacht?
Man macht hier keine Termine ab.
Das gibt es nicht.
Hier gibt es Sonnenaufgang
und Sonnenuntergang.
Termin abmachen!
Wir haben Glück und finden ihn.
Zusammen mit seinem Schwiegervater.
Hola!
(Lachend) Hola!
Der berühmte Edgar Montes.
Wir haben Sie überall gesucht.
In der ganzen Gegend.
Gehen wir rein und trinken Kaffee.
- Gerne.
Was uns Sorgen macht,
ist der Zugang zu unserer Farm.
Auch unsere Nachbarn,
die Familien Gachai und Cosmen,
leiden unter dem Zustand.
Wie können wir
Unterstützung beantragen?
In der Regenzeit können wir den
Kaffee nicht runtertransportieren.
Letztes Jahr hatten wir
grosse Verluste deswegen.
Bist du morgen zu Hause?
- Ja.
Morgen gehe ich nach Gallos,
dann komme ich vorbei.
Einfach vor 16 Uhr.
Um neun?
- Ja.
Gut, um 9.
Schwegler
will konkrete Projekte realisieren.
Einfach Geld zu spenden,
sei reine Symptombekämpfung.
Wenn wir bessere Strassen haben,
können die Leute
mehr Kaffee produzieren,
weil die Infrastruktur da ist,
um den Kaffee ins Tal zu bringen.
Dann ist der Nutzen davon
langfristig.
Sie können mehr verkaufen,
haben mehr Einkommen.
Und dadurch haben sie
mittelfristig ...
... ein besseres Leben
oder mehr Optionen.
Wir sehen uns morgen um 9 Uhr.
- Genau. Danke!
Ich bin überrascht, wie schnell
sie sich auf einen Termin einigen.
Was dieser wert ist,
erfahre ich später.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Ich erlebe Schwegler
als sehr engagierten Schaffer.
Diese Eigenschaft
wird von den Einheimischen geschätzt.
Alle mögen ihn.
Er gibt jedem Arbeit,
lehnt niemanden ab.
Er ist wirklich so.
Er ist wirklich einfach ein Guter!
* Sanfte,
langgezogene Panflötenklänge *
Nicht alle sehen in Schwegler nur
den Guten, viele auch den Goldesel.
Das erzählt mir seine Frau,
als wir am frühen Abend
Richtung Schule fahren.
Die Menschen denken,
dass Thomas und ich reich sind.
Aber das sind wir wirklich nicht.
Aber das ist die Mentalität
der Menschen hier.
Die Sitzung heute ist darum wichtig.
Wir wollen klarstellen,
dass die neue Schule kein Geschäft,
sondern etwas Gutes für
die Kinder ist - für ihre Zukunft.
Die Menschen hier wollen Geld,
sie versuchen solche Situationen
auszunutzen, das wollen wir nicht.
Die Wände der Schule sind durchnässt,
sie kann jederzeit einstürzen.
Schwegler ist der Initiator
dieses Projekts.
Seine Firma finanziert
einen Teil der neuen Schule,
der andere soll
über Spenden zusammenkommen.
Wir möchten wissen,
was eure Erwartungen und Hoffnungen
für die neue Schule sind?
Wir bekommen von niemandem
Unterstützung.
Wenn ihr uns helfen könnt,
sind wir euch sehr dankbar.
Zum Treffen
sind nur Frauen und Kinder gekommen.
Angesprochen
wären aber v.a. die Männer.
Väter können helfen,
die Schule zu bauen.
Wir bringen das Geld,
sie packen mit an.
Nur zusammen
können wir etwas bewirken.
Thomas und ich sind
nicht in der Lage, Löhne zu zahlen.
Das liegt nicht
in unseren Möglichkeiten.
Das Projekt
liegt der 33-Jährigen am Herzen.
Sie kommt selber
aus einfachsten Verhältnissen,
konnte nur die Grundschule besuchen.
Als ich sah, hier wird etwas
benötigt, wollte ich etwas bewirken.
Die Kinder sollen
nicht das Gleiche erleben wie ich.
Sie sollen das haben,
was ich nie hatte.
* Sanfte Panflötenmusik *
Im Regenwald
herrscht bereits emsiges Treiben.
* Sanfte Panflötenmusik *
* Sanfte, einzelne Streicherklänge *
Komm, steh endlich auf!
Aus diesem Schlauch kommt das einzige
Wasser - umgeleitet vom Bach.
Während der Regenzeit ist es braun.
In der Nacht wird Schwegler
oft von Ratten geweckt.
Dass ein Produzent von Spitzenkaffee
so wohnt, überrascht mich.
Es ist entschleunigend, im Vergleich
zum Leben in der Schweiz.
Man ist fokussierter,
weil man weniger abgelenkt ist.
Sei dies ...
Sei das durch Anrufe, durch ...
... Internet ...
... Fernsehen ...
Man wird etwas geerdeter -
und das tut gut!
Es ist aber auch anstrengend
und manchmal fehlt mir
der Komfort der Schweiz.
Schwegler studierte Betriebsökonomie
und baute ein internationales
Netzwerk von Produzenten,
Importeuren,
Exporteuren und Röstern auf.
Jetzt ist er Kaffeefarmer und
zahlt sich pro Monat 4'000 Fr. aus.
In der Schweiz
könnte er als Betriebsökonom
ein Vielfaches verdienen.
Es geht nicht alles
von heute auf morgen.
So eine Firma aufzubauen,
braucht extrem viel Geduld und Atem
und finanzielle Risiken.
Da haben wir sicher noch
einige Jahren abzuzahlen.
An diesem Morgen
bekommen die Arbeiter ihr Geld.
Schwegler hat sein ganzes Erspartes
in diese Firma gesteckt
und zusammen mit Investoren
seinen Traum
einer eigenen Kaffeefarm realisiert.
Es hat Phasen gegeben,
in denen ich nicht wusste,
wie die Rechnungen bezahlen.
Aber ich bin nie total ...
... zusammengebrochen.
Vielleicht darum, weil ich von
Natur aus ein positiver Mensch bin
und weil ich zu sehr daran glaubte,
dass es funktioniert,
was wir machen.
Und ...
Es gibt immer Lösungen.
Wenn man es schafft, souverän
zu bleiben und das durchzustehen,
gehen wieder andere Türen auf.
Die Tür zum Strassenprojekt
bleibt heute wohl zu.
Um 9 Uhr hätte er kommen sollen?
Genau.
Würde er jetzt kommen,
wäre er noch ...
Das wäre ja ein Wunder - 9.45 Uhr.
Das wäre natürlich ...
... absolut pünktlich.
Sie mussten lernen,
dass die Uhr in Peru anders tickt.
Das weiss man hier. 9 Uhr ...
Das ist für ihn ein Begriff.
Er hat keine Agenda,
in die er sich 9 Uhr notiert.
Der steht einfach morgens auf ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob er das hier
noch auf seinem Radar hat.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück
und er kommt heute noch vorbei.
Und sonst müssten wir
noch einmal runter zu ihm.
Vielleicht noch zwei-, dreimal
und irgendwann steht er sicher da.
* Lockere Panflötenmusik *
Mit dieser Hartnäckigkeit
hat er schon einiges erreicht:
Die Gesamtqualität seines Kaffees
wird mit bis zu 87 von 100 Punkten
eingestuft.
Er hat schon einige Preise gewonnen.
Im Kaffeemarkt zu überleben,
sei trotzdem ein Kampf.
Willst du Brot von unserem Anbau?
- Gerne.
Hier noch Mandarinen.
Auch von deinem Anbau?
- Nein, die haben wir auch bekommen.
Das ist genug, sehr nett.
Ups!
Die Gastfreundschaft
ist einmalig in Peru.
Also ...
- ... wenn sie einen mögen.
Wenn sie einen mögen, ja und ...
Meistens mögen sie einen.
Wann nicht?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich bin nicht streitsüchtig.
Ich bin eigentlich
ein harmonischer Mensch.
Es gibt immer Situationen,
in denen es nicht geht.
Es ist ein Killerargument,
Businessmann zu werden,
wenn man nicht gerne streitet.
Das musste ich lernen.
Ich bin immer gerne
mit allen ausgekommen.
Es gibt im Geschäftsleben ...
... immer wieder Situationen,
die entstehen
und wo man sich missversteht,
in denen man sich betrogen fühlt ...
... und in denen man streiten
und kämpfen muss,
um nicht zu verlieren.
Senora Wiki,
ich dachte, es sei näher.
Ja, es ist weit.
Ich bin vor Hitze fast gestorben.
Schau, hier ist die Hose kaputt.
Eine Firma in einem fremden Land
von Null aufzubauen
und sich gleichzeitig
für die Region einzusetzen -
mich beeindruckt sein Engagement.
Es ist wichtig für mich,
einmal von dieser Welt
zu gehen und sagen zu können:
"Ich konnte im ganz kleinen Rahmen
vielleicht etwas Positives
beitragen."
Ich glaube, ...
... die Menschen sind nur glücklich,
wenn sie ein Gegenüber haben,
mit dem sie sich austauschen können.
Wenn man andere Leute ...
Man kann etwas beitragen.
Alles andere
ist vielleicht schön und bequem.
Aber ob es langfristig
erfüllend ist?
* Peruanische Musik im Hintergrund *
Da habe ich meine Zweifel.
Was macht das?
Drei Soles.
- Tres Soles.
Mucha gracias. Hasta luego.
Nos vemos.
Chao!
- Chao. Nos vemos.
(Leise) Gracias.
* Schwungvolle Panflötenmusik *
Die Welt
ein kleines Stückchen besser machen -
das ist ihm zweifellos gelungen.
Ich bin gespannt,
wohin ihn sein Weg noch führt.
* Schwungvolle Panflötenmusik,
Stimmengewirr *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2019